darkest hour is about five days that  have been in May of 1940 when Great  Britain decided to stay in the Second  World War the Germans have encircled 16  British and French divisions we are  looking at the collapse of Western  Europe in the next few days looked like  they were facing impossible odds  almost everybody wanted to negotiate a  peace except one man and that turned out  to be the one man who mattered unlike  most Churchill movies it's exciting and  it captures the essence of the man and  the thing that he did your helmet looks  just like him  it's shocking he captures his spark and  his quickness I'm interrupting you would  you like to see how somebody lived his  life in a crisis who lived his life  about as well as anybody ever did it's a  wonderful thing to say everybody should  wanna see  [Music]